لا تزال العاصمة الأوكرانية كييف على أهبة الاستعداد
للحرب ، فنحن في
وسط المدينة تمامًا وكما ترون هناك
حاجز للدبابات تم إنشاؤه هنا
بأكياس الرمل من الواضح أنه موقع
دفاعي وهذا شيء تراه حقًا في
جميع أنحاء  مدينة بأكملها بها
الكثير من نقاط التفتيش والكثير من الجنود على
قوات الدفاع البرية أيضًا ،
ولمجرد إعطائك فكرة ، فنحن
حرفياً في وسط المدينة هناك ،
ترى الميدان بالطبع
في وسط العاصمة الأوكرانية
في  في نفس الوقت ، على الرغم من أنك
تشعر هنا الآن أن الناس
هنا لديهم مساحة أكبر قليلاً للتنفس
أنهم يشعرون بمزيد من الأمان قليلاً
بسبب بعض المكاسب التي حققتها
القوات الأوكرانية على
سبيل المثال عند نقطة تفتيش مثل هذه
ترى حركة مرور سيارات أكثر
بكثير مما رأيناه على سبيل المثال
خلال اليومين الماضيين ، هناك
المزيد من السيارات التي تمر هنا ،
ومع ذلك بالطبع
لا يزال الوضع في غاية الخطورة  مع
الروس يقولون إنهم ضربوا مستودعًا للوقود
جنوب العاصمة الأوكرانية ،
وبشكل عام بالطبع ، لا يزال القتال
مستمرًا على مقربة من المكان الذي نحن فيه.
مدينة لا في الغربية
وهذه هي التداعيات المباشرة ،
حيث سمعت سلسلة من الانفجارات في
جميع أنحاء المدينة ، يمكنك أن ترى هذا
العمود الأسود الضخم من الدخان ينتشر في
جميع أنحاء المدينة ، ليس فقط
عمود الدخان هو الذي يضخم النيران.
أه
مهم حقًا وفي الأسفل يمكنك
أن ترى أن هناك أطقم إطفاء
تحاول
يائسة محاربتها يبدو
بصراحة أنه جهد غير كافٍ
فالخراطيم التي يمكنك رؤيتها وهي مستهدفة
في تلك النيران تبدو صغيرة جدًا
بالمقارنة مع تلك النيران لا تزال
مشتعلة بشراسة وانظر  كما لو أنهم
مستعدون للقيام بذلك لبعض الوقت ، ما هو
غير عادي هو أن هذا يقع إلى حد كبير
داخل حدود مدينة ليف إنه
قريب جدًا من
المنازل ، إنه مكان إقامة  منطقة داخلية قريبة جدًا من
بعض المباني الشاهقة
على اليسار مباشرة من مركز تسوق ضخم ،
ومن الواضح أن هذا جزء من حملة وتكتيك مستهدفين للغاية من
قبل
الروس لأنه في اليومين الماضيين ، كان
هناك عدد
من مستودعات الوقود في مواقع مختلفة
عبر  لقد تم تدمير البلاد من
خلال صواريخ كروز الخاصة بهم التي تم إطلاقها غالبًا
من السفن البحرية التي نعتقد أنه في
البحر الأسود أواخر الأسبوع الماضي كان هناك
مستودع وقود كبير بالقرب من
كييف اليوم في وقت سابق من يوم السبت
أعلنوا أنهم ضربوا
صاروخًا آخر بالقرب من ميكولاي الآن هنا  في أقصى غرب
أوكرانيا في مدينة la viv phil black
cnn levitt غرب أوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
لذا